bulldozers and Earth diggers are taking
over in the Quake devastated areas
the recovery operation is in full swing
those trapped under the rubble were
retrieved and buried now workers face
the daunting task of clearing the debris
the structure of this building has been
severely damaged
order was given to knock it down
for weeks and maybe months excavators
will have to dispose of mountains of
rubble
what was once a thriving Community is
now reduced to shuttered concrete and
steel
officials are debating how to move
forward they want to make decisions on
whether students at this school should
be moved to tented school or relocated
to Marrakesh for a year
the high school principle is desperate
haunted by the memories of the students
who lost their lives
it's sad there's nothing we can do
students are my children and I feel
heartbroken when I think about the ones
who died in the earthquake they were so
excited about the start of school and
this strategy happened I can't find the
right words to express it
Engineers will have to decide whether
entire communities should be permanently
relocated particularly near the
epicenter of the earthquake
clearing the rubble along a vast area is
going to be a long and difficult process
and it's not clear yet if the
authorities will be able to deploy heavy
equipment into Villages built on top of
mountains weather damage is extensive
as the wreckage is being cleared Aid is
trickling into the most affected areas
this is a mobile Bakery put into place
by the police he makes 10 000 loaves of
bread a day
which is the staple food of Morocco
this is a delicate Mission because it
makes huge difference for the Quake
victims we are working non-stop to
ensure steady supply of bread for as
long as it takes
bread is then airlifted or transported
to the makeshift camps
families here in tahanoud Italian jolted
by the earthquake are still traumatized
I have no idea what's next with the
aftershocks almost happening daily we
don't know what will happen tomorrow for
now excavators are working around the
clock sifting through the wreckage as
soon as they cleared away the debris
from collapse building reconstruction
will start survivors of the Quake
grappling with pain and hoping to
rebuild their lives and move on
south of Marrakesh
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera